Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new marvel thunderbolts movie video they
just revealed that they're actually making a
thunderbolts movie in the next couple of years
so i'll explain what's happening who's going
to be on the team they mentioned some people
specifically during the article we have
a lot of theories that they've confirmed
and as some of you will know there's a bunch
of deleted scenes from the earlier marvel
phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 movies referencing red
hulk and a lot of thunderbolts things that i'll
work into the video too so they're actually
stories like this they tried to do previously
and just left for future projects like what's
happening right now but if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's a bunch of really big stuff coming up
marvel also just announced that they're doing
a special disney plus day in september where
they're gonna do another preview releasing a
ton of trailers for upcoming stuff and right
now with the thunderbolts movie just being added
to the roster and deadpool 3 we really only know
what's happening up to 2024 which is only the
next couple of years so there's like a couple
other years of stuff that they haven't revealed
yet but you probably just saw in your fees just a
little while ago as of me posting this video that
marvel just confirmed their thunderbolts movie
confirming all our theories we all thought that
they were forming a thunderbolts team with val and
all her cameo scenes we also thought they could
be doing dark avengers but they just called it
thunderbolts so it's gonna start as a thunderbolts
project we're not gonna need a captain america
we're going to need a u.s agent and the surprise
is that it will start as a movie it's not going to
be a disney plus series at least at first the
person they had to direct and write the movie
is jake schreier he's not someone who's done a
ton of marvel stuff before so there's not a ton
of stuff that he's done related to this but
apparently they just say that his pitch blew
marvel away and they're pinching it basically
as their version of a suicide squad movie
which makes sense that's kind of how they portray
the team in the comics the way they're positioning
them inside the mcu at least this is a little
bit different from the way they started in the
comics it's just a bunch of anti-heroes and legit
marvel villains whose prison sentences are reduced
or they're given black ops missions that are just
too shady or they're just too outright morally
grey or dangerous for the avengers to take on
the missions there's this whole thing during
the valcamio scenes where she says that she's
working for someone else she's being paid by the
us government that would be thunderbolt ross at
the top of that food chain you did the right thing
taking the serum outside swing it has made you
very very valuable to certain people kind of a
legal gray area i'll explain how he's connected to
the vowel character because they've only hinted at
him in a lot of her cameo scenes like even though
she's the one that's going around doing all these
cameo scenes putting the team together she's
working for someone else inside the us military
the funny thing about the way the thunderbolts
started out though is that their name isn't
meant to be a play on thunderbolt ross's name they
were actually originally meant to be an evolution
of the masters of evil which is why baron zemo
started out leading the team but i'll explain
how they're changing that just a little bit for
the mcu version of the team it won't be exactly
like the comics but there'll be some easter eggs
for that the whole idea though is that thunderbolt
ross and valve were putting together their own
version of an avengers like team like a norman
osborne dark avengers type team that will just do
whatever he wants them to do no matter how morally
grey it is whereas during captain america's
civil war he had a big problem trying to get the
avengers to do what he wanted them to do signing
the sokovia accords val also literally tells us
agent john walker that they're looking for a team
of people who will do things that they can't call
regular falcon captain america to do kind of a
legal gray area and of course thunderbolts is the
franchise where you would do a red hulk character
there are a couple versions of red hulk in the
comics so i'll explain the twist of that character
and how they're different from the other members
of the whole family like bruce banner incredible
hulk jennifer walter she-hulk because we are
getting the she-hulk series and we are getting
bruce banner hulk back and he's currently in
professor hulk form so i know a lot of people
are asking who's going to be the main villain
of the thunderbolts movie if it's a bunch of
anti-heroes it always has to be some crazy twist
the deadline article with the marvel announcement
about them doing the movie specifically mentioned
thunderbolt ross being involved in the story
so i'll explain how they might include red hulk
even though the actor william hurt recently
passed away there are also literally scenes where
thunderbolt ross talks about taking the power of
the hulk the gamma power and using it for himself
what's inside of him but it all starts with
those teasers and the val cameo scenes that
we've seen so far there have been several scenes
starting with her cameo scene in falcon and winter
soldier where she recruits us agent john walker in
baron zemo now we didn't actually see her talking
to baron zemo but she talked about baron zemo
to us agent as if he's an old friend that she's
been talking to previously and they spent a lot of
those episodes positioning baron zemo's more of an
anti-hero willing to work with the heroes like the
new captain america falcon and winter soldier but
also being way more morally grey doing way shadier
things like killing those remaining flag smashers
that survived after the fact that'd be something
that he would do with valve's blessing because
val thunderbolt ross would want to get rid of the
flag smashers no matter what i would have killed
a bastard too nobody in there is mad at you about
that i mean you would have been doing him a favor
if you'd taken out the whole lot berensimo also
currently chilling out on the raft which is like
thunderbolt ross's secret prison for supervillains
that he doesn't put in other land-based prisons
there's also the sharon carter power broker
that they revealed at the end of that series she
tricked her way past the world security council
back into the u.s military and revealed that she
was going to have access that she'd regain to
all these weapons and tech inside the military
stealing stuff and just selling it to the highest
bidder using it is basically her own candy store
she's still based in madrapur still got her hands
in all kinds of shady stuff all over the world
so val would probably have her on speed dial too
for anything that she needed for the thunderbolts
that she couldn't put on the official us military
books so to speak her character is very much
in the tone of the vowel character right now too
like oh trying to actually help the world but also
doing really shady stuff at the same time then val
showed up closer to present day in the black widow
post-credit scene revealing that she'd already
recruited elena bolova in a given her orders
to kill hawkeye on the orders of someone else who
sounded like they've been working with the kingpin
character val doesn't work specifically for the
kingpin himself but during that she jokes about
other people higher up signing her paychecks
that's people like thunderbolt ross inside the
u.s military really high-ranking people who give
her orders or all these black ops missions then we
just saw the abomination in the shangshi movie
fighting wong in the ring and then going back
to the cube prison in his cell the cube is kind
of like the backup version of the raft another
high level prison for super villains just based
on land and he just came back in the she-hulk
trailer with she-hulk given orders by her law
firm to defend him in court their new superhero
defense team within her law firm that she's now
working for like defending super villains other
super powered individuals accused of crimes is
basically fed by people like val and thunderbolt
ross who are trying to keep these big marvel
villains superheroes anti-heroes out of prison
so that they can keep them going on shady missions
without too much trouble the deadline article also
specifically mentions ghost and winter soldier
being on the team and ghost does make sense even
though we haven't seen her in a while she's more
of an anti-hero now at the end of ant-man and the
wasp with access to quantum energy she can phase
through different dimensions through objects at
will but them including winter soldier might have
just been speculation on their part even though
he does have a checkered past and he is kind of an
antihero they kind of positioned him at the end of
falcon and winter soldier as if his sentence had
been commuted and the us government viewed him as
just being completely above board now but even
though he's supposed to be a good character he
could also still wind up on that team val could
still wind up hiring him they could also bring
back a version of taskmaster who survived the
end of the black widow movie or they could always
give the mantle to someone else too just because
classic taskmaster is a very thunderbolts type
of character in the whole thing with the red hulk
is if they don't want to actually use thunderbolt
ross as a huge character because he is the first
version of red hulk they can still use val or
another big twist anti-hero character as their mcu
red hulk abomination right now is the stand-in for
an actual hulk character on the team short term so
red hulk is something that they'd work up to for
like a huge wtf reveal but red hulk isn't meant
to be an evil character even the thunderbolt ross
version it's more the same type of energy of the
uncontrolled rage and collateral damage you saw
from the classic version of the incredible hulk
bruce banner before he learned to control his rage
and create the professor hulk balance persona
she-hulk is kind of the same idea too in the
comics she's more frequently portrayed especially
in the trailer as a professor hulk like balanced
state where she retains all of her intellect but
she also has most of the strength of her hulk
form too they don't specifically list who the main
villain of the movie is in this big announcement
article since this is being done in the tone of a
suicide squad movie though all these former marvel
villains anti-heroes have to fight someone who's
even more dangerous even more of a threat even if
it's not a legit villain so outside of a brand new
marvel character they could always introduce my
leading theory without more information is that
val gives them a mission to take down the bruce
banner hulk and they do the movie as more of a
world war hulk type of story with the bruce banner
hulk going off the rails and losing control
there been rumors recently about them doing
a world war hulk story in the movies they have
the she-hulk series where he's a huge character
and mark ruffalo revealed a couple years ago that
he'd been pitching a new hulk story to kevin feige
separately from what was happening during she-hulk
and they might just be having more problems with
universal releasing their own hulk solo film
so they just use them in hulk tv series and
they use them in other people's movies also the
thunderbolts appeared for the first time in the
incredible hulk number 449 trying to take out the
hulk so if they're doing the comics their first
mission would be to literally go after the hulk in
the comics they were led by baron zemo so i think
they're trying to pitch baron zemo leading the mcu
version the team as well but the big connection to
what's happening in the mcu right now in marvel
phase four after avengers end game is that in
the comics the thunderbolts were created as a
response to this power vacuum after a major event
had decimated the avengers the fantastic four
other major teams so i left this huge power vacuum
kind of like you saw after avengers end game
like a bunch of avengers died some of them are
still alive but the team has been fractured they
haven't had avengers 5 yet they haven't formed
the new version of the team so the whole idea
is that thunderbolt ross and the mcu is working
on the world security council he wants to protect
the world the same way that iron man did but he's
way more hardcore about it the way the iron man
was during avengers age of ultron like protecting
the world in a suit of armor in a way that was
just way too overboard leading to all kinds of
problems like norman osborne dark rain type of
energy creating the dark avengers for our nation
and for our way of life i intend to put a harness
around it so thunderbolt ross and valve would want
a team of avengers level characters powerful
characters who would just do whatever they
told them to do without questioning it and that's
who the thunderbolts are what'll probably happen
though because abomination is such a big character
during the she-hulk trailer of the series is we'll
see a val cameo scene during she-hulk where
she'll probably show up to actually recruit
him to just like she showed up during falcon and
winter soldier and during the black widow movie
but everyone let me know in the comments which
other characters do you want to see them put
on that initial roster there was a brand new
thor love and thunder trailer video that i'm
working on right now that i'll post on friday
i'm also working on a new boys episode there was
also a brand new marvel series that premiered on
disney plus i'm doing videos for every wednesday
make sure you enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss any of that stuff links for my brand
new marvel episode videos in the description below
you can click here for that brand new black adam
trailer video in easter eggs and click here for
my brand new thor love and thunder trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!